foreign
hey Dana welcome to the Ramsey Show
well we're excited how can we help
well I recently first off I watch you
all the time you Rachel Dr John George
love you guys you've saved my life in
many ways thank you so much I truly
respect all of you well thank you
um
absolutely so I saw something the other
day that said
poor people use debit cards rich people
use credit cards I don't have any credit
cards I don't have any debt I have great
Investments I have money saved up I only
have living expenses I have a great job
I don't have any credit cards should I
well I don't know who said that I guess
it sounds like you ought to stay off a
tick tock yeah you didn't see that at a
Cracker Barrel did you
yeah you wouldn't have seen it there you
wouldn't have seen it where actual rich
people hang out or actual poor people
hang out yeah so I don't know they sound
to me like they got that exactly
backwards my net worth several hundred
million and I hadn't had a credit card
in 30 years so I don't know where they
got that
okay so but then don't I need a credit
card to like rent a rental car or I
haven't had a credit card I haven't had
a credit card in 30 years
and I travel more than any two of you
put together so
um okay yeah they they take a debit card
I mean you have to work some of the
situations you have to work at not every
uh of the rental car companies take them
no and there are some situations where
you have to do a workaround on it but
it's not this idea that you you know
so here's the thing people get credit
cards from mainly one reason
so they can buy crap they don't have the
money to buy
right and then they justify it going
well I need to build my credit
that's what they say because that's what
rich people do rich people build their
credit bull crap all the rich people
that we interview say they get out of
debt and stay out of debt
and that's how they got rich they don't
pay payments all the time because see
there's only one way to build your
credit go in debt right
right why so you can build your credit
why so I can go into debt why so I can
build my credit why so I can go into
debt why so I can build my credit it's a
dog chasing its tail it's called the
Great FICO scam
laughs
so that that that's why I haven't had a
FICO score in 30 years
really yeah really mine's mine's uh that
they said I don't exist I'm not here I'm
off the grid
wow because I don't have any credit I
don't have any I have had no interaction
with debt in well over 30 years of any
kind and so I have zero on my credit
bureau report so I have a zero credit
score they they say it's indeterminable
I call it zero
right Dana what do you think you need
credit for what do you think you need a
credit score for right now
if I want to buy a house one day
not true you have to talk to George
Campbell he bought a house with zero
credit score yeah and you got a mortgage
by the way yeah uh he did it with manual
underwriting it's called with Churchill
Mortgage
and got the same interest rate that
people with an 800 score would have
gotten
but you know what George did don't you
they turn around and paid the house off
and so at 32 years old he and Whitney
are millionaires
so you know that that's what they did
and it wasn't because he makes a
bazillion dollars here because I don't
pay that good
laughs
actually I do but George was George got
it paid off for he started making bank
so there you go but anyway
and Whitney Whitney makes up the oh yeah
two good incomes there that's it but
anyway they uh yeah so no Dana it's a
scam and whoever said that I mean listen
you got to be careful where you take
Financial advice broke people walk
around all the time with financial
advice
don't take Financial advice from broke
people
I mean it's just it's crazy don't you
know you're broke Finance professor in
college just telling you how you need to
do stuff and he's got no money a broke
Finance Professor is like a shop teacher
with missing fingers I mean come on yeah
there's issues here so yeah all right
open phones Folks at triple eight eight
two five five two two five you know Ken
what's interesting is if you look around
you say okay the vast majority of the
population is something I don't want to
be yeah then don't do yeah what they're
doing that's right the vast majority of
them look good and have no money they
have cars they can't afford vacations
that they're still paying for after they
got home
their net worth is horrible they're
counting on the government to provide
for them when they get to retirement
because they're not saving for
retirement their children are a student
loan looking for a place to happen
because they're not saving for college
this is normal
in America 78 of Americans live paycheck
to paycheck that means 78 of Americans
are not worthy to give out Financial
advice because they're freaking broke
so when your broke friends have an
opinion just smile yeah no thank you
that'd be like me have an opinion on
growing hair on my head yeah yeah that'd
be dumb yeah I mean if there's none up
there well you could be an expert on
what not to do yeah but I don't even
know what caused you know I can claim
it's DNA so here's what's going on Dave
we live in the claim it's going broke I
could claim my hair fell out for a lot
of reasons but at the end of the day I'm
not good at growing it on the top of my
head so you should not take my hair on
top of your head advice
so here's what I want people to hear
just because it's marketed so heavily
and everybody else has bought it doesn't
mean it's true we have marketing
messages that have been going on for
decades you pick an area of life where
you see a commercial it does take the uh
let's take the uh prescription drugs
they are marketing these things are good
for you but the list of side effects are
longer than the actual thing it's
helping and but they Market it with
these happy a billion people the
commercial is the disclaimer you know
just know and so it's it's marketing and
so you know we've got to understand that
it's been marketed to you that you need
a credit score it has been marketed over
and over it's the most aggressively
marketed product by time spent on the
air yeah dollars spent on Advertising of
any product in history of humans exactly
right
MasterCard visa and American Express's
combined marketing budget is billions a
year it's way more
than beer right it's way more than I
don't know cars put all the car
companies together it's a tenth of what
the credit card just the credit just the
three credit card companies I'm not
talking about people like so if I who
also advertised to get you into debt or
other people like this it's nothing like
that I mean Bank of America God help us
you know I mean put all those budgets
together to get you into debt oh my God
it is the most marketed product in the
history of the world and guess what
it's also the most purchased
that's why this show is so popular
because people are up their eyeballs in
debt and can't breathe highest
percentage Dave of all time of six
figure earners that are living paycheck
to paycheck and it's largely credit card
debt man when I was a kid if you made a
hundred thousand dollars a year you were
automatically Rich yeah now you're just
automatically in debt this is the Ramsay
show